alright guys so if you saw my Avengers
review and since the views are a lot
higher than my subscriber base I'm
assuming you did this is my buddy John
the flipping and you didn't see our
other previous review hey basically if
you saw in the Avengers review I teased
that you know we're gonna do a spoiler
filled discussion The Avengers is you
know no holds barred our thoughts just
everything we feel like you know just
know that we can talk about mental
feelings exactly these things we can say
that we normally wouldn't say in a
review so you guys probably both know we
loved it I mean it's amazing it was an
nerd nerd a what is it nerd Yasim nerd
Adam nor nerdgasm Gotham good good job I
sperm to my pants that's another way I
could put it get ready for heavy
spoilers so if you haven't seen it why
would you be watching this if you
haven't seen the movie everyone seen the
movie how much it's almost made what
eight hundred million dollars a billion
dollars it's made a billion dollars
worldwide okay everyone's seen it
speaking of that do you think this movie
is gonna get close to Avatar or at least
surpass maybe Titanic's domestic
Schneider you know be Titanic avatar
that's it's hard to guess I think it's
gonna get really close I think overall
when it's all said and done with blu-ray
and DVD purchases and rentals I think it
will beat it I agree I think that when
like everything is and I don't know
about domestically like at the box
office
I know like it could be Titanic at least
it's comic book driven where avatar
could be you know grand mole 65 would go
see that that's true yeah but then again
my mom you know she's in her sixties and
she really liked the Avengers and she
didn't wash that Matar she didn't have
that desire to watch an advertiser we
wanted to see The Avengers the thing
that I loved about this movie to me was
just the fact that it was able to
maintain such a consistency of
characters I mean there are so many
characters in this movie and I was just
expecting it to be all jumbled but it
wasn't yeah with big egos I mean you got
Thor you got you know Hawkeye why you
know Hawkeye doesn't exist we're gonna
set him he's an afterthought he's the
crust that you find on the side of the
toilet bowl he is the one that it wasn't
as development but that was because you
know he got turned early on he was evil
for like half the movie
yeah yeah you know he had an excuse to
not be as develop this the others he was
weak that's why you got turned movie
first started you know you're at the
shield underground base and I was a
little underwhelmed the first five
minutes of that yeah there was a big you
know implosion and Loki but it felt like
a TV series when I first started out you
didn't it feel
I mean Joss Whedon came off a lot of TV
shows so I mean that's possible I just
really like that intro with Loki he
comes he just killed a whole bunch of
people you know it's not like he kills
people when they turned some people and
I got the idea that Loki is like a
hardcore dude and he's gonna he's gonna
cause problems right then as soon as
that scene was done that's when the fun
started for me I mean you needed that to
set it up as soon as it all these
characters started getting introduced
you know the Hulk and Scarlett Johansson
I mean just almost popping out of those
pleather pants every you could see the
scenes in the back just wanting to say
let me go she's one of those characters
where you when you were watching and
you're just like why dissing voluptuous
is the word love us I was surprised that
much screentime at how much story a
movie revolved around Black Widow I was
glad too because a lot of people were
commenting for the movie they're like oh
why is Black Widow in there she's taking
her gun she's cocking her gun and
everyone else has all these powers and
it's like where's she gonna do in it but
no she was great
there's a lot I'm surprisingly I mean
she survives a Hulk attack I liked how
they showed her like they gave her they
made her go visit Hulk and Shion talked
with Hulk so that set up the fact that
later she would have then have that
confrontation with Hulk because you
almost see a confrontation with them in
the beginning when he like slams the
table and she gets all scared you know
that sense of the fact that later they
actually are going to have it a little
bit of a confrontation and it's just so
well-written they really like brought
out that she is very you know cerebral
she she's not just physical like she
tricks men into you know give her what
she wants just like a normal woman which
is like a lot of special abilities of
flexibility she can trick me all she
wants I will jump to the end of the
movie real quick just for her but
there's that one scene where she jumps
off
Captain America's little thing and jumps
and grabs a hold of like this alien
spacecraft going like 400 miles per hour
I was like that was a little beyond her
bill night not happen a little just a
tidbit
out of her reach in this movie I forego
the you know the implausibility of
reality it's just you know whatever but
I mean I understand I just I really like
the way they set up those characters the
way Banner was introduced my Ruffalo is
just great I mean he I liked it or
ignored I even been mine Eric Bana as I
thought Eric Bana looked the part
yeah but more than Edward Norton did I
think this was just he got it right the
thing that was so cool about the Hulk in
this movie for me was the fact that they
understood the comedy of Hulk like they
got the fact that a big hulking green
guy it's funny like they're that's the
funny thing to happen to someone yeah
each previous Hulk movie like whenever
he would Hulk out
that was looked at as a failure it was
like oh I failed yeah it's like a key in
him yeah you can't have fun with that
but at the end of this movie he like
accepts that anger he's like it's like
my secret is I'm always angry and that
line yeah also you can have fun with it
cuz he's like accepting it and it's fun
yeah all the other Hulk movies made him
into a monster rather than a superhero
let's talk about Mark Ruffalo now when
he was first cast were you like really
yes and no like who the who I like Mark
Ruffalo ah
I liked I loved him in collateral I've
liked him in everything I've seen it
laughs Castle I haven't seen that
actually right in the record the
character of Bruce Banner is like a
really insecure kind of innocent you
know kind of maybe a little bit it's not
very self-assured kind of person and I
was that's kind of how much Mark Ruffalo
sometimes comes across it's just like a
really timid guy I was annoyed with all
the the hate and I was telling people
like it's gonna be good he's gonna be
good in the movie and I knew I thought
the fact that he was a scientist first
of all and Edward Norton I'm sorry he
didn't come across he just came across
as a guy on the run I completely agree
he was just like a fugitive or something
let's talk about when they get to the
the Helicarrier the whole second act of
the movie is on that thing yeah they can
I mean it's surprising how long they
were on the damn battleship with fans on
the side of it which by the way it just
it didn't look like it should float um
but that's it was cool though I liked it
once again implausibility is out the
window
I'm just saying anyway yeah I really
enjoyed I think they got it the how we
should look the cool thing about that
ship is like you need a character who is
experiencing that stuff for the first
time so that we as the audience
he didn't like feel it through him and
that's why they had Captain America
there because Captain America is still
like fresh and new to that time period
and so and I love how he like he takes
the 10 bucks in the hands that Nick Fury
10 bucks like you have a yeah you know
so yeah yeah that was my 1940s voice
that was a very good impression I really
like the whole hoping the Captain
America where he's in the gym punching
bags he doesn't comprehend what you know
new things are does entire man calm old
man or something Brent hit an old man
that's because I don't I don't know man
healed man yeah yes
but he's an alcoholic anyway Oh
originally they actually Joss Whedon
said that he scripted the entire script
of basically him Captain America and it
was like basically them talking back and
forth the whole movie really that was
like the whole basis of the movie mmm
you didn't want to make it just that
focused on them basically what happens
on the ship is what makes them realize
they have to be a team because like when
the agent coulson dies that's what
that's the one that was the catalyst to
make them realize the seriousness of the
situation the fury blatantly lies and
says he has blood on Captain America's
trading cards right which was like the
needed push oh yeah they also had to
work together to fix the ship when I'm
broke
welcome it was like their way of
learning how to work now I want to talk
about that that very comic book II very
obvious combining forces on the ship now
you have one of the turbofans went down
and you have Iron Man he has to jump in
there and push it start it whatever and
then there's a big red switch that
Captain America has to pull it's true
like let's give some Captain America
something to do here push the Reds pick
the big red switch yeah that's what
you're capable that's true whatever it
is I mean yeah it's the big red switch I
get it when the coolest things happen in
the entire movie when Incredible Hulk
and Thor get in there we go fight great
which I comic book wise it all mate like
they even them out just perfectly like
you bought what was happening did you
like the part where Thor's waiting for
his hammer
yes and he's actually and they make the
joke that he actually does have to wait
like til gets to where he's going he's
actually sitting there waiting for it
for a few so I wasn't just like Dom okay
it was like
has to come through the wall for it
would be kind of plenty to see like
where it went it's just something some
guys are seeing there's like a shower
and a hammer goes between us live that
would be pretty funny actually I'm
surprised I didn't do that one of the
things that I was hoping that they
wouldn't do is because I know a little
bit of the comics no one can live stores
hammer no one can do that I like how
they show the whole thing try to lift in
it's like the ground is being like
grabbed yeah that good that mean that
gave me the little as you put it nerd at
nerdgasm Gaza those two words don't fit
right together in my mind I don't know
why maybe because I've never used it
before many Anna from India yeah that
conversation was awesome I mean I'm not
just saying that yes it was awesome in
that sense but one things I said in my
review is it's really easy to like geek
out about this movies about how the
special effects and everything but like
they set up confrontations with people
it wasn't just a fight scene there's a
difference between a fight scene and a
confrontation because like if you look
at the the end of Empire Strikes Back or
the end of Return the Jedi
that's a confrontation that's not just
we're gonna fight and see who wins
there's emotional stuff going on they
sent this kind of stuff up during the
movie and it all it all gets rewarded at
the end when you see all the little
things they sort of fit into place and
to talk about character development and
actually flushing out emotions and
making things to make sense you know the
scene when you have the Hulk in the you
know and black widow there Eric Eric van
or Eric Bay Eric Bana
no Bruce Banner good job he's underneath
the pipes and him and Scarlett Johansson
laying there and he's getting kind of
mad and frustrated and she's trying to
calm him down and he's trying so hard
not to and then he just snaps and almost
kills her and it just shows that he is
incapable of controlling himself that
shot of her on the ground
just laying her a helpless on her with a
pipe across her and I'm like if I would
have found her in that room I don't
think the Hulk would have been a threat
you know what else though is kind of
cool there's a shot right before he
turns to the Hulk fully yeah he like
turns around and looks at her he's got
you see his eyes that was like the
humanizing of that you're like all he's
be sad right now like you just felt that
like he's sad he's a sad hole he doesn't
want to be Hulk right now but that's
great because you got the you got the
real Hulk out where he's mad but then at
the end he gets he and he get you get
the accepting I like doing this
like when Captain America is like he
gives all your orders and he's like and
Hulk no cuz like it's like smash and
then look like you know it's like it's
like yes like you feel the adrenaline
like the scene where Robert Downey jr.
and Loki are in the iron stark tower
just talking I love that scene except
the trailer has ruined it because you
just kind of did you kind of knew the
that's one thing the trailers the two
things the trailers gave away yes it was
great to hear that I have a Hulk line it
was cool I would have liked to have not
known that and the other thing is they
shouldn't have shown a Hulk catch Iron
Man at the end they shouldn't show them
yeah yeah cuz I knew that was coming
from like the last 20 minutes of the
movie I didn't know that was gonna be
the big an scene when I saw the other
last entire part of this movie the big
you know basically what Loki is doing is
trying to you know teleport or import
people from space to come to earth to
take over to make human slaves and
they're using a MacGuffin which was the
blue testicles
okay now let's compare that to another
movie that just came out last year yeah
transformers 3 the exact same storyline
for the ending there are similarities
there are similar it's pretty damn
similar a big thing goes up in the sky
opens up a whole things are falling down
are similarities just the only thing I
can think is they came out in such a
short amount of time but I'm sure Joss
Whedon was probably already planning a
lot of that ending and he probably saw
it transformers he was like crap hey I'm
just I'm just putting it out there not
that we're giving well he might be but I
mean giving support to my company I've
given enough support of the guys who
else has to you know start his second
call I like that the whole ending scene
it's like the Transformers 3 ending was
just a lot of nifty special effects for
45 minutes and had some cool fights and
you know a building caved in and Sam
Witwicky screamed a lot oh I thought we
were talking about the end of the
Avengers first I thanks for that I could
tell the difference except the end of
the Avengers was more entertaining and
yes and they're renewing the filling
there were characters in like situations
and you like you stuff was happening
okay it wasn't just mindless yeah
explosion you know I think I think they
did what they could with everyone doing
their own little part obviously you know
Captain America can't do what Thor can
do
so he's kind of like on the ground just
holding back holding back the crowd and
putting up caution tape that's the other
thing I said in my review initially I
like seeing all the people come into
play like you could see what Black Widow
and Hawkeye can do they can help like
the people out of the bus and stuff
without scores or you know squishing him
like the Hulk or Jagger but I also liked
the fact that they showed Black Widow
she had like some blood on her head
coming from her mouth like you got the
fact that G is filled woman yeah no
basically I think Joss Whedon did
everything in his power to make her as
strong of a female character as possible
amongst all these yeah she made Hawkeye
look like a would you like that big epic
shot of Hawkeye when he's falling off
the building he's just shooting is he I
actually love that and then he just
shoots the arrow that has a rope and it
needs to ease into a window oh god I got
away thank God I don't have to fight I
love you since I have no powers I'm
gonna hide in here for a little bit or
Hulk standing aside and just you know
after their confrontation they still
have a little bit of grudge and he just
punches them and he flies out of frame
great best part of the entire movie to
me Loki a rag doll with home yeah Hulk
grabs Loki slamming around makes him
like basically Loki has this big self
complex issue I'm a god
no you're not you're your little bitch
on the floor with a mullet you go wet
your hair back damn the camera zooming
in on Loki he's like I'm a god you are
nothing you are mindless beasts and they
just see him like a dream I mean that
part Oh
roid rage on man perfection like that is
the one of the funniest moments I've
ever seen in a movie
finally Tony Stark kind of has a little
better read he redeems himself only yeah
and then they set that up in the movie
because I show Captain America talking
to him he's like you're not a hero I've
seen you on the news and stuff you just
don't you just do this for yourself you
know like they set him in the sea Tony
Stark space and there's like a moment of
recognition where he's like that might
actually be true like he doesn't want to
admit it cuz even in the first Ironman
in the second Ironman when Ironman one
ended he was still like a narcissistic
guy like he's like I am Iron Man what
you liked yeah of course I mean Tony
Stark tomorrow they're juniors one of my
favorites but and even in Iron Man 2 he
still never really got the whole good
this movie was like his character arc
really I mean at the end of the movie it
is
to sacrifice himself he didn't know he
was gonna make it out and then Hulk
obviously catches him at the end and I
like how he set it up so we're getting
really nitpicky and really weird here
but I like how the war was on the ground
and they didn't just show like everyone
standing around like oh I hope he
doesn't hit the ground door was actually
ready to fly it was like infinite scary
so he would have done it yeah but Hulk
just beat him to it and then when he
lands and Hawk throws him off I'm like
you know yeah he's like oh that's so
funny I mean Hulk is so funny in this
movie like they understood Joss Whedon
is such a good writer I mean he just he
knew or each of these characters he's
he's for the fanboys could you imagine
him writing like transformers and making
it like good the humor is actually funny
yeah they said the little robots humping
each other's legs is that whatever
cocaine biscuits or whatever they have
yeah there's no comparison to the other
hoaxes I'm sorry this is what The Hulk
is like in the comics when he turns
around and says that's my secret I'm
always angry that is the character of
Hulk in the comics and I got a lot of
questions on my review saying like
what's the one line you're talking about
Chris the line that made the Hulk and I
that's the line I'm talking about that
line is just I agree that is Hulk you
know and he turns around he punches that
thing I mean the theater like claps like
it was just it was great even even
though I've fanboys out there who play
like Marvel Alliance and all those games
I liked when Tony Stark or Iron Man shot
his little blasting off Captain America
shield yeah that's in a lot of the video
game and I think that was like a little
that shot where it goes like all around
the whole city and shows all yeah yeah
like the Hulk the Hulk takes a piece of
the ship sticks it in the ship and then
Thor goes boom yeah I do like combos or
something everyone's like combo time Sam
if you guys don't know I've gotten some
questions on my review anyway like who's
the purple guy that's Danos and I did
some research because I'm not like that
hardcore of the comics he is the owner
of the Infinity Gauntlet which I
actually I'm not sure what that is but
knowing the whole thing about his
character is that he is obsessed with
death the personification of death like
he doesn't give a shit let's just die
he loves dead like he's literally like
he's like aroused by death and so that's
why when he's like necrophiliacs aroused
by corpses either way anyway when the
guy he's kneeling perform at the end and
he's like to fight humans is to court
death and Thanos turn around and smile
that's because that he's a very enticed
by that okay so he loves the idea of
death to me I think that's what the the
next Avenger movie needs it needs a
bigger epic villain that you just
honestly don't think they can be low-key
just was very confused and he had a lot
of delusion yeah a lot he was injured it
was an emotional teenager that his his
father didn't love him anymore he was
adopted boohoo and now he's got a great
line by the way he's adopted line
oh yeah the adoptive line and the Point
Break line where he calls Thor question
of course you would like looks like
Patrick Swayze from Point Break there
are similarities the final after credits
scene though is that this so simple
they're just sitting there eating their
shawarma stuff that Iron Man was talking
about but that is honestly my favorite
after credit scene ever they're just
sitting there and Thor just takes like
this giant bite of whatever that is I
died I just casual so funny they're all
just there in their outfits just like
eating in a restaurant the restaurants
like caved in that was so close and they
shot that like a week before the actual
American release and if I read about
that Chris Evans actually had a beard by
that time for another role so if you
look at the scene closely that he's kind
of like hiding his face a little bit and
like they're I didn't notice that yeah
that's true did you have any dislikes
about that man I honestly don't if you
haven't checked out our use that we did
for battleship and what to Expect When
You're Expecting yeah we saw that okay
then go ahead and check out those videos
if you want to see more of us together
if you haven't checked out John videos
check them out subscribe to him he does
blue or updates it's great get flicked
Wow
don't cut that that's good get flicked
[Music]